while studying at Cambridge University
Oppenheimer poisons his professor's
Apple after he's forced to miss the
beginning of a lecture and clean up his
sloppy lab work that poisoning was no
creative flourish either as Oppenheimer
did indeed inject his tutor Patrick
blackett's apple with chemicals and it
caused more of a scandal than what's
shown in the movie in the film
Oppenheimer wakes up in a panic the
following morning and rushes back to the
classroom to find his Idol Niels Bohr
about to take a bite to prevent a
disaster he says that he spotted a
wormhole and tosses the Apple in the
trash in reality Oppenheimer was
struggling with more serious mental
illness his questionable perception of
reality led to a diagnosis of dementia
precox which is a now outdated term for
schizophrenia in the real version of the
misguided Revenge plot block it never
ate the apple Oppenheimer was neither
arrested nor expelled partly due to
conflicting accounts and his father's
influence the ordeal was seen as a cry
for help and he managed to seek
psychiatric care